texas governor greg abbott joins me now
so do you expect
mayor adams and and mayor bowser to come
to texas and see for themselves what's
going on
you know jesse i really wish they would
because
public officials across the country they
do need to realize the magnitude of the
chaos created by biden's open border
policies there up in arms about a few
thousand people coming into their
communities over the past few months
listen in any one sector in the state of
texas
we have more than 5 000 people coming
across that sector every single day
and so listen we're full in the state of
texas our communities are overrun and i
started busting people to washington dc
when local officials could not handle
the number of people that had come
across our border and it's time that
these officials in new york and i'm glad
you mentioned the new york times they
haven't reported about this they haven't
written about the chaos at the border
maybe finally the new york times will
also start talking about the chaos that
the border caused by the byte
administration's change of all the
measures that were put in place by
president trump where president trump
actually did secure the border so clear
this up for people you're not
handcuffing migrants and forcing them
unwillingly on the buses and telling
them you're going to new york you're
going to washington d.c as they try to
fight to get off the bus that's not
happening right
exactly they sign a waiver of agreement
when they board that bus okay good
because some of these mayors bowser in
particular
she can't imagine why anybody would ever
even want to go to dc
she's like they can't actually want this
to be their final destination washington
d.c the nation's capital
it's it's an indictment on our own
governance do you understand when mayor
adams says well we have a housing
problem why can't they just find housing
in texas what would your response be to
that
the cartels are not looking for housing
in texas
actually the cartels that are coming
through texas they are actually trying
to get to new york where they can
distribute the fed stall that they're
bringing across the border
exactly well i think he should take you
up on the offer maybe he could take a
bus just like the migrants you get the
full experience the bus the free cell
phone the whole thing and they need to
have a better perspective all right
texas governor gregory thanks for coming
up was there one more thing you wanted
to add
i was going to say yeah so when we drop
them off they're empty so they can get a
free ride back
with gas this expensive it might be
costly but you know it's worth the ride
thank you governor
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else